La séance est ouverte.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par Emmanuel Blairy pour le
Rassemblement National.
- Emmanuel Blairy: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à Bruno le
Maire, ministre de l'Economie.
Partout en France, nos
agriculteurs sont inquiets.
En 10 ans, c'est 100.000
exploitations agricoles qui ont
disparu.
Le bilan macroniste est un vaste
plan social qui ravage
l'agriculture française.
Lors des assises de la finance
publique, vous avez déclaré faire
des économies pour protéger notre
nation contre le risque de la
dette.
Rappelons votre bilan: vous avez
fait 600 milliards d'euros de
dettes sous le mandat précédent et
150 milliards de déficit sous le
dernier PLF.
Pour cacher vos responsabilités,
vous annoncez un nouveau plan sur
le dos de nos agriculteurs.
Sous couvert de fiscalisation sur
le gasoil non-routier, nos
agriculteurs vont payer plus cher
le carburant.
Nos agriculteurs ne sont pas la
pour gérer les errements de
l'exécutif.
Vous souhaitez leur faire payer
votre incompétence avec un plan de
10 milliards d'euros d'économie
dont ils supporteraient 15%.
C'est saboter toute une filière en
même temps que de mettre en danger
notre souveraineté alimentaire,
déjà très impactée.
Pouvez-vous vous engager à vous
exclure de votre plan les
entreprises agricoles pour
soutenir la filière?
On vous demande de retrouver le
bon sens paysan.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Je constate à nouveau que vous
contestez le fait que nous avons
accumulé des déficits pendant la
période de Covid.
Nous avons accumulé beaucoup de
dettes pour soutenir les
restaurateurs et les entreprises.
Il y a une nécessité de soutenir
la transition vers les énergies
fossiles.
Nous sommes dans un système où les
français payent deux fois.
Ils payent sur des carburants qui
polluent notre planète et
l'environnement.
Ils payent ensuite pour réparer la
pollution qui a été engendrée par
cette dépense fiscale.
Nous devons disposer de leviers
qui nous permettent de financer la
transition écologique.
Il a été annoncé par le ministre
de l'Economie que de manière
progressive, à l'horizon 2030,
nous allions revenir sur cette
niche fiscale du gasoil
non-routier.
Ça doit se faire en
responsabilité.
Nous devons avoir une cohérence
par rapport à nos objectifs
climatiques, pour sortir des
énergies fossiles.
La responsabilité, c'est de ne pas
plonger des secteurs économiques
ou agricoles dans de grandes
difficultés par cette décision.
C'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons engagé un travail de
concertation et d'échanges avec
l'ensemble des filières
concernées, l'agriculture, le BTP,
les transports routiers...
Ce travail va nous mener cet
automne à avoir un débat sur le
calendrier que nous proposerons
pour la suppression de la niche
GNR qui sera très progressive.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Une réponse?
- Emmanuel Blairy: Je pense que
c'est surtout fait pour faire les
poches de nos paysans.
Vous êtes en train d'appliquer une
politique de la zigzag.
C'est celle qui consiste à se dire
que s'il y a bordure, il y a
trottoir.
La France ne marche pas comme ça.
Nous avons besoin d'un véritable
plan.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Mes chers collègues, je suis
heureuse de souhaiter en votre nom
la bienvenue à une délégation du
groupe d'amitié Mexique-France, de
la chambre des députés des
Etats-Unis du Mexique, conduite
par son président.
Applaudissements
Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Maxime
Laisney pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Maxime Laisney: Merci beaucoup.
Après une augmentation du coût de
la vie de 6%, après une nouvelle
hausse des loyers autorisés de
3,5%, c'est une énième attaque
contre le pouvoir d'achat que vous
allez mener avec l'abandon du
bouclier tarifaire.
Une suppression qui frappera plus
de 2 millions de nos concitoyens,
contraints à une sobriété, pas du
tout raisonnable, mais bien subie.
Depuis 2022, il y a une hausse de
10% des procédures pour loyers
impayés.
Cela ne vous suffit pas.
Tout le monde met en garde sur les
contrats à prix ajustés au marché.
Vous décidez d'exposer les
familles à une extrême volatilité
sur les prix du gaz.
L'été dernier, ils étaient 20 fois
supérieurs à ce qu'ils étaient
observés une semaine plus tôt.
En appliquant bêtement les règles
de concurrence européenne, vous
préférez prendre nos concitoyens
en otage d'un marché qui ne marche
pas, plutôt que de les protéger
contre cette nouvelle bombe
sociale.
Vous préférez conforter les
multinationales énergétiques.
Le plus grand nombre devra bientôt
choisir entre faire cuire ses
pâtes ou se chauffer.
Quelle rustine allez-vous inventer
pour pallier votre entêtement
idéologique?
N'avez-vous rien compris du
message de nos concitoyens depuis
les gilets jaunes?
Ils ne veulent pas seulement
survivre.
L'énergie, c'est la vie.
C'est un bien commun et c'est un
droit.
Vous liquidez les conquis sociaux
issus de la libération, dont font
partie les tarifs réglementés.
Je vous demande: allez-vous
renoncer à cette nouvelle casse, à
cette nouvelle injustice sociale?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Vous comparez la
fin
de cela aux prix du marché.
Ces prix évoluent chaque mois au
prix du marché.
C'est un index qui est fondé sur
les prix du marché.
Quand les prix se sont envolés,
c'est le bouclier gage, que cette
majorité a mis en place, qui a
protégé les Français d'une
augmentation du prix du gaz.
Il a permis d'éviter une
augmentation massive des prix de
plus de 20%.
La France Insoumise a-t-elle voté
ce bouclier gaz?
Non!
Vous n'avez pas voté la seule
mesure efficace pour éviter cette
envolée des prix.
Vous parlez au moment où les prix
ont redescendu.
Vous n'avez pas voté une seule des
mesures de protection en faveur
des Français, des entreprises ou
des collectivités locales.
Bouclier tarifaire des
électricités?
Non.
Bouclier tarifaire du gaz?
Chèque énergie, chèque bois,
filet de sécurité?
Non!
Vous refusez d'agir pour libérer
notre pays de sa dépendance aux
énergies fossiles.
Avez-vous voté pour l'accélération
des énergies renouvelables?
des procédures sur le nucléaire?
Monsieur le député, derrière vos
belles paroles, il y a la
détestation dogmatique du
nucléaire, votre préférence pour
le gaz russe et le charbon
allemand.
Vous voulez rendre notre pays plus
dépendant d'un point de vue
énergétique.
Laissez ce gouvernement travailler
pour protéger les Français!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Henri
Alfandari pour le groupe Horizons.
- Henri Alfandari: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre chargé de
l'Industrie.
Je souhaite appeler à votre
attention la situation
d'incertitude vécue par beaucoup
de chefs d'entreprise dans ma
circonscription en regard des
tarifs des fournisseurs d'énergie
et des mises en oeuvre votées dans
cette assemblée.
Nous sommes nombreux à entendre
cette situation.
Si les aides apportées ont
largement bénéficié aux personnes
qui les ont perçues, de nombreuses
entreprises sont confrontées à des
situations intenables et sont
menacées de fermeture.
Le prix de nombreux contrats sera
réajusté à la fin de l'année.
Des reprises mensuelles sont
constatées dès à présent.
Les entreprises et les
exploitations concernées se
retrouvent donc avec des sommes à
ajouter à leur facturation
normale, et elles ne peuvent tout
simplement pas honorer les sommes
demandées.
Certains entreprises éligibles à
des mesures de soutien se sont
trompées de dispositifs ou n'ont
pas su remplir les demandes
correctement.
Par ailleurs, nous allons préparer
le prochain hiver, et de larges
mouvements tectoniques sont à
l'oeuvre: bouleversements
géopolitiques, difficultés
d'approvisionnement en énergie...
Ce contexte de tensions sur les
ressources pourrait maintenir des
tendances inflationnistes.
Ma question est double.
A court terme, pouvez-vous nous
dire ce que nous devons expliquer
à nos entrepreneurs sur la
difficulté de lisibilité des
factures et de gestion de
trésorerie liée aux reprises
mensuelles de bouclier ou
d'amortisseur?
A moyen terme, ces dispositifs
s'éteignant, et sachant que nous
ne voulons pas les renouveler,
quelles mesures envisagez-vous
pour que les consommations
électriques soient à des niveaux
supportables pour notre système
économique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est au ministre chargé
de l'Industrie.
- Roland Lescure: Merci de votre
question qui nous permet de
rappeler que les mesures votées
par cette majorité pour faire face
à un défi absolument historique
l'hiver dernier, des prix
historiquement hauts et des prix
historiquement volatiles du fait
de la situation internationale,
ont été une stratégie gagnante.
Nous avons protégé les ménages,
comme nulle part ailleurs en
Europe.
Nous avons aussi protégé
les entreprises et nous
avons adapté notre outil de
production énergétique, électrique
et gaz, à la situation actuelle.
Je voudrais remercier les
personnels d'EDF qui ont travaillé
d'arrache-pied pour remettre à
niveau l'appareil nucléaire.
Je veux aussi remercier les
personnels de TotalEnergies qui
vont nous permettre d'assurer un
approvisionnement en gaz de
qualité pour l'hiver prochain.
Vous m'interrogez sur l'hiver
prochain.
Même si la situation s'est
extrêmement améliorée, les prix
ont retrouvé des niveaux normaux,
nous ne devons pas nous endormir
sur nos deux oreilles et nous
devons préparer l'hiver prochain
en continuant à négocier
l'évolution du fonctionnement du
marché de l'énergie, de manière à
ce que l'on arrête de dépendre du
charbon allemand ou d'autres
ressources internationales.
D'autre part, nous devons traiter
les cas d'espèce qui font que
certaines entreprises font face à
des facturations anormales.
Dans l'immense majorité, les
fournisseurs d'énergie ont
appliqué directement les
ristournes liées au bouclier
énergétique que vous avez votées
sur les factures énergétiques.
Un certain nombre de consommateurs
font face aujourd'hui à des
incompréhensions, face à des
factures dans lesquelles des
erreurs ont été commises.
Dans chaque département, nous
avons un commissaire départemental
aux sorties de crise qui est là
pour les aider.
Ces commissaires accompagnent déjà
plus de 10 000 entreprises qui
font face à ces défis.
N'hésitez pas à les y envoyer.
Ils aideront.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Naegelen.
- Christophe Naegelen: Merci.
Le printemps et l'été voient
fleurir les déplacements de gens
du voyage.
Les terrains aménagés ont été
payés par les impôts de nos
concitoyens.
Malgré les efforts faits, nous
constatons encore et toujours des
implantations de manière illégale
et brutale chez les particuliers
ou sur des terrains communaux.
C'est le cas dans le nord, chez
notre collègue.
Dans sa commune, 200 caravanes ont
forcé leur installation dans le
champ d'un agriculteur qui venait
juste de finir de le faucher.
Mes questions sont simples.
Comment expliquons-nous à nos
associations qu'on leur refuse une
manifestation parce qu'elles ont
oublié un simple papier?
Comment expliquons-nous, alors
même que nous sommes en danger
d'incendie, que nous laissons 200
caravanes s'installer sur du foin
sec?
Comment expliquer que nous allons
avoir tout un terrain et de la
forêt souillée par des déchets
dans une zone classée et dans un
périmètre servant au captage de
l'eau?
Comment expliquer
à nos collectivités impuissantes
cet envahissement?
Comment explique-t-on à tous nos
concitoyens à quel point il faut
respecter la loi pour le bien
commun et en fin de compte, que
nous laissons agir impunément ceux
qui ne la respectent pas?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Je sais qu'il est bien difficile
pour les élus locaux de faire face
à l'arrivée d'occupations
illégales.
Vous évoquez ici les gens du
voyage.
Je voudrais vous rappeler la loi.
Je voudrais vous dire ce que le
gouvernement compte faire.
La loi, c'est qu'il faut également
être en pleine légalité de la loi
qui oblige les collectivités
locales, les départements et les
intercommunautés à avoir des aires
d'accueil pour les gens du voyage.
Sinon, les gendarmes ne peuvent
pas procéder à l'expulsion.
Il se peut que, par ailleurs, des
trous soient dans la raquette pour
empêcher les policiers et les
gendarmes de venir.
Comme par exemple, lorsque le
maire ou les propriétaires ne
portent pas plainte dans le délai
de flagrance.
Cela explique que les policiers ne
peuvent intervenir que dans le
cadre d'une décision de justice,
particulièrement longue.
Nous devons sans doute travailler
là-dessus.
Nous allons continuer de faire
évoluer la législation.
D'autre part, il se peut que les
caravanes s'installent sur des
terrains dont on ne connaît pas le
propriétaire, ou le propriétaire
ne porte pas plainte lui-même,
peut-être contre rétribution.
Il faut laisser aux maires, même
s'il s'agit d'une propriété
privée, ou du préfet, le soin de
se porter responsable pour porter
plainte.
Je partage la colère des élus
locaux et des citoyens qui font
face à ces difficultés.
Je peux vous promettre qu'avec le
ministre Christophe Béchu, nous
allons proposer un texte issu de
vos collègues sénateurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno
Millienne pour le groupe
démocrate.
- Bruno Millienne: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
chargé du Renouveau démocratique,
porte-parole du gouvernement.
Le Journal du Dimanche n'est pas
paru dimanche.
L'ensemble de la rédaction a
décidé de faire grève pour
protester contre la nomination
d'un nouveau directeur de la
publication aux opinions bien
affirmées.
Madame la ministre de la Culture
s'est exprimée face à la
situation.
Jusqu'à peu, il dirigeait un
journal condamné pour injure
raciste.
C'est le symptôme d'un mouvement
plus général.
Cela remet en question
l'indépendance des rédactions et
la pluralité de la presse.
Depuis la consécration de la
liberté de la presse par la loi de
1981, nous avons encadré l'un des
piliers de notre régime
démocratique, sans en altérer la
force.
Nous avons ainsi réussi à assurer
l'indépendance des journalistes et
à lutter contre la désinformation,
sans attaquer cette liberté
fondamentale.
J'ai aujourd'hui l'impression que
la situation nous échappe.
Jamais depuis la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale, nous n'avons
assisté à une stratégie aussi
agressive de mise sous tutelle
idéologique de notre paysage
médiatique.
Cette situation quasiment inédite
met en question la liberté des
presses dans un pouvoir
économique.
Cela met en cause aussi le rôle de
l'ARCOM pour garantir le rôle des
opinions.
Face aux nouveaux défis que doit
affronter notre paysage
médiatique, comment pouvons-nous
continuer d'assurer l'indépendance
journalistique et le pluralisme
des opinions?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran, porte-parole du
gouvernement.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Merci pour votre question.
Evidemment, le gouvernement
n'ignore pas ce qu'il se passe
aujourd'hui au JDD et les craintes
que cela peut soulever de toutes
parts.
Bien sûr que la presse d'opinion
est légale en France, et ce au nom
du pluralisme des médias et de la
liberté de la presse, qui sont des
principes fondamentaux dans notre
démocratie.
Les inquiétudes sont vives dans
une partie de la profession.
La ministre de la Culture n'a pas
attendu l'actualité récente pour
se saisir des sujets de protection
du pluralisme.
Elle a identifié ce souci dès son
arrivée, il y a un an.
En décembre, elle a réuni des
parlementaires pour engager la
réflexion sur l'évolution de la
loi de 2016 qui vise à renforcer
le pluralisme des médias.
La commission des Affaires
culturelles s'est également saisie
à travers une évaluation de la loi
qui est en cours.
Cette mission est déjà au travail.
Est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
que ce qui existe déjà dans la
loi?
Comme les chartes déontologiques,
relatives à l'honnêteté et à
l'indépendance?
Le droit actuel ne comporte par
exemple aucune disposition de
nature à garantir l'indépendance
des rédactions à l'égard des
tentatives d'influence ou
d'émission de la part
d'actionnaires.
Le gouvernement souhaite réfléchir
à comment renforcer les garanties
de pluralisme nécessaires à notre
démocratie.
Toutes les pistes sont ouvertes.
Le président de la République a
annoncé qu'il y aurait des états
généraux de l'information où nous
pourrons aborder l'ensemble des
problématiques.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Sébastien
Jumel.
- Sébastien Jumel: Madame la
présidente, madame la ministre,
avec l'inflation, les Français
sont assommés.
Assommés par l'uppercut des prix
alimentaires, par l'explosion des
prix de l'électricité, par votre
refus idéologique de compenser
l'inflation par la rémunération du
travail, le salaire.
Malgré cela, le 1er juillet
prochain, votre gouvernement en
rajoute une louche en franchissant
un nouveau cap dans la
libéralisation du marché de
l'énergie et avec la fin des
tarifs réglementés de vente du
gaz.
Ainsi, près de 7 millions de
Français vont subir directement la
jungle spéculative autour du prix
du gaz.
Le quoi qu'il en coûte est bel et
bien fini pour la France qui
travaille.
Nous l'avons mesuré, le bouclier
tarifaire pour les prix de
l'énergie, et en particulier ceux
du gaz, ne protègent pas les
locataires de HLM, ni même ceux
vivant en copropriété.
Après le 1er juillet, quel
Français pourra se sentir protégé
alors que les prix fixés pour les
contrats pour la chaudière, pour
la maison?
Cela dépendra de l'humeur de la
bourse.
Elle nourrit les marchands de
savonnettes de l'énergie, mais
elle ne préserve pas le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages.
L'énergie n'est pas une
marchandise.
Elle est un bien de première
nécessité.
Renoncez à votre rêve de
transformer les Français en
traders de l'énergie.
Avec l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales et des associations de
consommateurs, nous vous demandons
solennellement le retour aux
tarifs réglementés du gaz et de
l'électricité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci
beaucoup.
Comme je l'ai indiqué à l'instant
à monsieur le député Laisney, les
tarifs réglementés du gaz ne sont
pas un tarif plafonné.
C'est un tarif de marché.
Il est donc extrêmement volatile.
Ce n'est pas lui qui protège.
Que change concrètement cette fin
des tarifs réglementés?
D'abord, elle concerne un quart
des consommateurs qui utilisent
aujourd'hui du gaz.
Nous leur avons écrit pour les
rassurer et les informer sur les
options qui s'offrent à eux.
D'abord, rester chez leur
fournisseur actuel et basculer
automatiquement sur une offre que
nous appelons offre passerelle,
qu'Engie a mis en place à la
demande du gouvernement.
Cette offre s'appuie sur un indice
repère que nous avons créé.
Les prix du gaz étant actuellement
redescendus, les Français qui y
souscriront bénéficieront d'un
tarif de 10 à 20% moins cher que
ne l'était le tarif réglementé.
C'est la réalité du moment.
Ensuite, ils peuvent signer un
nouveau contrat avant le 1er
juillet avec le fournisseur de
leur choix.
Aucune autre démarche n'est
nécessaire, et il n'y a aucun
risque de coupure ni changement de
compteur.
Aujourd'hui, l'offre passerelle
est 10 à 20% moins chère que le
coût du tarif réglementé.
Par ailleurs, le gouvernement et
la majorité continuent de soutenir
les Français les plus en
difficulté.
Dès fin 2021, les chèques énergie
exceptionnels ont bénéficié à 12
millions de Français.
Ce sont 12 millions de ménages qui
ont bénéficié de cette nouvelle
campagne jusqu'à 277 euros.
- Sébastien Jumel: Vous ne manquez
pas de toupet.
Vous nous répondez sur le prix du
gaz aujourd'hui alors que vous
savez que les marchands de
savonnettes vont spéculer sur la
vie des gens au coeur de l'hiver.
Le prix du gaz et de l'électricité
empêche les ménages de faire
bouillir la marmite!
Vous n'êtes pas à l'écoute de la
France d'en bas!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Natalia
Pouzyreff pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Natalia Pouzyreff: Ma question
s'adresse à la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères.
Le monde a été témoin de la
tentative de putsch menée par le
groupe Wagner.
Nous avions appelé à inscrire ce
groupe sur la liste des
organisations terroristes.
Le Kremlin semble reprendre la
main, mais la réaction de Poutine
qui évoque une guerre civile, cela
montre combien cette crise est
prise au sérieux.
Cela montre la guerre des clans
qui se joue à l'est de l'Europe.
Cette crise laisse envisager une
bataille de succession sous forme
de transition chaotique et
violente.
Il est vraisemblable que seule une
défaite sévère en Ukraine ne soit
de nature à déstabiliser ce régime
autoritaire.
Si les forces en présence de
Prigojine restent difficiles à
évaluer à ce stade, cela
questionne la crédibilité de
Poutine en tant qu'interlocuteur
pour négocier une paix durable en
Ukraine.
Le président français a rappelé
que la situation justifie
pleinement le soutien que nous
apportons aux Ukrainiens.
L'instabilité croissante en Russie
et le repositionnement des troupes
Wagner en Biélorussie suscitent
l'inquiétude de certains de nos
alliés.
Devons-nous redouter une
déstabilisation accrue dans la
région?
Plus largement, et malgré les
zones d'ombre qui demeurent, que
pouvez-vous nous dire des échanges
qui ont eu lieu entre les membres
du G7 et de l'Union Européenne sur
la guerre en Ukraine?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée, vous l'avez
dit, la première chose qu'il faut
dire, c'est que les événements du
week-end recèlent de nombreuses
zones d'ombre.
Sans doute, leurs conséquences
n'ont-elles pas fini de se faire
sentir.
A l'évidence, elles ont mis en
lumière des fissures, des
fractures et même des failles au
sein du système russe.
Celles-ci sont très largement dues
à la guerre que fait la
Russie à l'Ukraine.
Nous avons menées au cours des
derniers jours de nombreuses
consultations.
Le président de la République et
ses homologues se sont entretenus,
et je me suis moi-même entretenue
avec mon homologue ukrainien et
mes homologues du G7.
Je le répète, nous n'avons en rien
l'intention de nous immiscer dans
ce qui est une affaire intérieure
russe.
Mais notre responsabilité reste
plus que jamais de continuer
d'être extrêmement vigilant et de
continuer à aider l'Ukraine à se
défendre.
Une vigilance et une aide qui sont
plus que jamais nécessaires dans
ce moment d'instabilité nouvelle
qui est causé par la Russie, et
dont elle-même commence à voir les
conséquences sur elle-même.
Avec mes trois homologues des pays
baltes, nous avons réaffirmé que
cette guerre met la Russie dans
une impasse.
Une impasse militaire, économique,
diplomatique, morale, évidemment,
mais désormais aussi une impasse
intérieure.
La Russie doit comprendre que le
temps ne joue pas pour elle, que
nous restons aux côtés de
l'Ukraine et que le coût de son
agression contre l'Ukraine va
continuer d'augmenter pour elle.
Elle doit comprendre qu'elle doit
rendre à l'Ukraine la paix et la
souveraineté qui sont les siennes.
Il est plus que temps.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur le
président Marleix.
- Olivier Marleix:
Hier, un collectif a demandé au
Conseil d'Etat l'annulation de
l'article premier des statuts de
la Fédération française de
football qui interdit toute tenue
manifestant ostensiblement une
appartenance religieuse.
Le rapporteur du Conseil d'Etat
propose de leur donner raison.
Il faut avoir la naïveté d'une
pâquerette pour refuser de voir
dans ce mouvement du proxénétisme
ou de la provocation.
J'ai regardé sur Internet la tenue
vestimentaire des équipes de
football féminines dans de grands
pays musulmans.
L'équipe de football du Maroc: pas
de hijab.
En Algérie: pas de hijab.
En Tunisie: pas de hijab.
Au Sénégal: pas de hijab.
En 2004, le président Chirac, qui
était ami avec les pays arabes, a
légiféré pour conserver à l'école
son statut de sanctuaire
républicain.
Si dans trois semaines, le Conseil
d'Etat suit son rapporteur,
serez-vous prête à suivre
l'exemple du président Chirac et à
légiférer pour mettre nos
enceintes sportives à l'abri du
prosélytisme religieux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Merci, monsieur Olivier Marleix.
Je veux avant toute chose
réaffirmer mon attachement et
celui de tout le gouvernement au
respect du principe de laïcité.
Vous m'interrogez sur une affaire
en délibéré suite à l'audience
publique qui s'est tenue hier.
Je ne saurais m'exprimer sur une
affaire en cours.
Le Conseil d'Etat fait son travail
en toute indépendance et
impartialité.
Cette séparation des pouvoirs est
au coeur de notre République.
Monsieur le président, je mesure
les interrogations que suscite
cette affaire.
Nous attendons la décision et nous
allons accompagner la Fédération
française de football et les
autres fédérations autant que de
besoin.
Quelle que soit la décision, je
peux vous assurer que je suis
totalement mobilisée avec la
ministre des Sports pour le
respect strict de nos principes
républicains dans le sport, en
particulier la laïcité et la
neutralité du service public.
Nous sommes mobilisés pour
garantir l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes, notamment
dans le sport.
Nous sommes mobilisés pour lutter
contre toute forme
de radicalisation.
Nous sommes en première ligne pour
combattre toutes les formes de
séparatisme dans les clubs.
3500 clubs ont été contrôlés en
2021-2022, dont une trentaine ont
donné lieu à des mesures contre
des dérives séparatistes.
Nous allons renforcer les
contrôles et nous n'allons pas
hésiter à fermer des clubs qui
font la promotion d'une idéologie
radicale ou séparatiste.
La ministre des Sports va signer
des partenariats pour renforcer la
lutte contre le séparatisme.
J'ai confiance en nos clubs et en
nos instances sportives.
Le gouvernement restera pleinement
mobilisé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le président.
- Olivier Marleix: Je vous ai posé
une question simple: êtes-vous
prête à légiférer, comme l'avait
fait le président Chirac?
Vous n'avez pas répondu à cette
question simple.
Nous n'en serions pas dans cette
situation si votre gouvernement
avait accepté les amendements du
groupe Les Républicains en 2021
sur la loi séparatisme.
Vous les avez rejetés, et nous
serons au rendez-vous.
Nous allons déposer un texte pour
préserver la neutralité dans
l'enceinte sportive.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le président.
La parole est à Guillaume Garot.
- Guillaume Garot: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, en
Mayenne, aucun hôpital ne va
assurer les urgences la nuit
pendant l'été.
C'est votre bilan depuis six ans.
Vous nous expliquez que tout est
sous contrôle et que cela finira
par aller mieux.
Nous savons que c'est tout
l'inverse.
Ce que nous vivons dans notre
pays, c'est une dégradation sans
précédent de l'accès aux soins.
Depuis le 1er décembre 2021, selon
SAMU urgences de France, 36.000
patients dorment sur un brancard
sans chambre attribuée.
Bien sûr, le problème ne date pas
d'hier.
Chacun porte une part de
responsabilité.
Madame la Première ministre, votre
responsabilité, c'est d'agir
vraiment.
Je veux rappeler que le Ségur de
la santé n'a pas produit le choc
d'attractivité qui était annoncé
pour les métiers du soin.
Je rappelle également que vous
avez refusé toute régulation de
l'installation des médecins
libéraux pour mieux les répartir
sur le territoire national, comme
le proposait notre groupe de
travail transpartisan.
Je rappelle également, et c'est
pire, que vous diminuez les
remboursements de certains
médicaments et de certains soins
dentaires, ce qui provoquera à
coup sûr du renoncement aux soins.
Notre hôpital brûle et vous
regardez ailleurs.
C'est l'ensemble de notre système
de santé qui craque de partout.
Quand allez-vous prendre la mesure
de l'urgence?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, cher
collègue.
La parole est à Agnès Firmin Le
Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Merci.
Monsieur le député, vous
m'interrogez sur la problématique
des urgences en Mayenne.
Grâce à la mobilisation de tous
les professionnels et pour faire
face aux tensions en ressources de
professionnels de santé qui
touchent les établissements de
santé ainsi que les organisations
libérales du territoire, les
professionnels se sont regroupés
avec la fédération
interhospitalière pour apporter
une réponse cet été.
Les urgences seront effectivement
fermées de 18h30 à 8h.
Les urgences vitales seront
assurées 7 jours sur 7 et 24
heures sur 24.
Nous pouvons remercier l'ensemble
du personnel de santé de se
mobiliser pour assurer une
régulation qui permet de répondre
à tous les appels qui sont donnés
au 15.
Monsieur le député, les urgences
vitales, et il faut le signaler,
seront bien assurées 24 heures sur
24.
Nous tenons à dire que le
gouvernement est mobilisé avec le
doublement des rémunérations des
gardes et la majoration des heures
de nuit.
Le sujet des rémunérations a été
tranché il y a quelques jours.
Il y a eu un vote.
La régulation n'est pas la réponse
aux besoins de santé de nos
concitoyens tant à la ville qu'à
l'hôpital.
Tout un panel de mesures est
étudié.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la ministre.
La parole est à Sophie
Taillé-Polian.
- Sophie Taillé-Polian: Merci.
Je voudrais exprimer tout mon
soutien et tout notre soutien aux
journalistes du Journal du
Dimanche.
Ceux qui ne les soutiennent pas et
qui appellent aussi à la
privatisation du service public de
l'audiovisuel, ce sont les mêmes.
Ce ne sont pas des républicains!
La liberté de la presse est
fondamentale dans la démocratie.
L'information est un bien public,
protégée par notre Constitution.
C'est ce qui différencie un
journal d'une agence de
communication.
Pour Vincent Bolloré, il suffit de
sortir le porte-monnaie pour
acheter les médias un à un et y
instaurer sa croisade idéologique.
Management autoritaire,
intervention directe sur la ligne
éditoriale, censure...
Partout où il passe, il vire les
journalistes qui font du travail
de terrain et qui sont attachés à
la déontologie pour les remplacer
par ses chroniqueurs d'extrême
droite.
Cet homme qui utilise les médias
pour instaurer son projet
politique, pardonnez-moi
l'expression, il se fout de notre
gueule!
Il se joue de notre attentisme.
Il déclarait qu'il
n'interviendrait pas dans les
médias, et que fait-il?
Un simple tweet ne peut pas
suffire pour exprimer ses regrets.
Je déposerai dans les prochains
jours une proposition de loi pour
donner un droit de regard aux
journalistes sur la nomination de
leur directeur de rédaction, comme
le propose un collectif
d'universitaires.
La soutiendrez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
J'excuse Rima Abdul-Malak, qui est
en déplacement à Marseille.
Dans cette enceinte, c'est le
ministre de la République qui vous
répondra, s'en tenant à ce
qu'exige l'Etat de droit.
En démocratie, les médias sont
indépendants.
Le rôle de l'Etat, c'est de
soutenir le pluralisme.
Le rôle de la justice, c'est de
sanctionner les actes
répréhensibles quand il y en a.
Imaginez un monde dans lequel les
ministres chargés de la culture
décideraient de retirer ses
responsabilités à un directeur de
rédaction?
Je sais que ce n'est pas ce que
vous dites.
S'il vous plaît.
C'est cette même Assemblée
nationale qui a déclaré que la
libre communication des pensées et
des opinions se fait dans le
strict respect de la loi.
L'imprimerie et la librairie sont
libres.
Si liberté et censure sont de
parfaits antonymes, liberté et
pluralisme se conjuguent
naturellement.
En 2021, plus de 400 titres ont
bénéficié d'aides, comme Le
Figaro, Libération, entre autres.
Le journalisme respecte le traité
de la charte de Munich.
Parmi les droits et les devoirs,
je retiens un devoir: ne jamais
confondre son métier avec celui de
publicitaire ou celui de
propagandiste.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à Marc Ferracci,
pour Renaissance.
- Marc Ferracci: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ce ne sont pas les parlementaires,
ministres ou élus qui doivent
définir la ligne éditoriale d'un
média, mais ce n'est pas non plus
le rôle d'un actionnaire.
Si nous sommes profondément
attachés à la liberté économique,
nous sommes également convaincus
que le respect de l'indépendance
éditoriale des journalistes est un
principe essentiel à la liberté de
la presse.
On pourrait juger comme une
péripétie la nomination à la tête
du Journal du Dimanche de l'ancien
directeur de la rédaction de
l'hebdomadaire de Valeurs
Actuelles.
Peut-on parler de péripétie
lorsque le responsable d'un titre
de presse condamné en appel pour
injures racistes prend la
direction d'un journal qui, depuis
75 ans, est attaché à la diversité
des opinions?
Peut-on parler de péripétie quand
30 sociétés de rédacteurs se
déclarent inquiètes de cette
nomination?
Elles affirment leur soutien à la
rédaction du Journal du Dimanche.
Peut-on parler de péripétie quand
tout ceci s'inscrit dans un
contexte de concentration des
médias qui justifie peut-être que
le législateur renforce le cadre
légal?
Certains pourraient invoquer le
principe de la liberté
d'entreprendre, mais il n'y a pas
la démarche de création d'une
entreprise de presse.
Il existe un garde-fou: se donner
tous les moyens de préserver
l'indépendance éditoriale des
journalistes.
Cela est stipulé dans la loi, en
particulier celle du 14 novembre
2016 avec plusieurs garanties.
Pouvez-vous nous indiquer ce que
le gouvernement entend faire pour
mieux concilier la liberté
économique et l'indépendance
éditoriale des journalistes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Pour reprendre les éléments de
réponse que j'ai donnés
précédemment, je voudrais rappeler
qu'il ne revient pas à l'Etat
d'interférer dans le choix d'une
rédaction du domaine privé.
Je pourrais ajouter une réflexion
personnelle.
Lorsque vous arrivez à la tête
d'une entreprise et que 99% des
salariés de cette entreprise
décident de se mettre en grève, ce
n'est pas anodin.
L'ensemble des journalistes ont
décidé de ne pas produire le JDD.
C'est la première fois en 75 ans
que ça arrive.
Peut-être que ce n'est pas à
l'Etat d'intervenir.
Si vous arrivez dans ces
conditions dans l'entreprise, la
question se pose de savoir si vous
prenez acte de la volonté ou non
des salariés de l'entreprise que
vous venez d'intégrer.
Vous m'interrogez sur l'évolution
qu'on pourrait apporter.
Il y a une évolution qui a démarré
de la part des parlementaires sous
l'égide de la présidente de la
commission des Affaires
culturelles pour réviser le cadre
de la loi de 2016.
La ministre de la Culture a
également engagé des travaux.
C'est un sujet important.
Le président de la République
souhaite aborder ce sujet dans le
cadre des Etats généraux.
Comment préserver des comités de
rédaction d'influences
extérieures?
Comment préserver les lignes
éditoriales?
Comment préserver le pluralisme de
la presse et son indépendance?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Caroline Parmentier, pour
le Rassemblement National.
- Caroline Parmentier: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à la
Première ministre.
Dimanche, votre ministre de la
Culture s'est crue autorisée à se
mêler de la ligne éditoriale d'un
journal français, média privé, et
à s'exprimer sur le recrutement de
l'un de ses journalistes.
Que la ministre de la Culture
décerne des certificats de valeurs
républicaines aux journaux
français est particulièrement
inquiétant pour la démocratie.
La ministre de la Culture et votre
gouvernement devraient avoir comme
premier principe la défense de la
presse sans que celle-ci subisse
la pression du pouvoir en place.
Ce n'est pas la première fois que
madame la ministre de la Culture
exerce des pressions.
Elle a menacé des chaînes de
télévision, CNews et C8, de ne pas
voir leur licence renouvelée et de
les priver de leurs fréquences.
Elle sort régulièrement de son
domaine de responsabilité pour
s'attaquer à des médias, à des
animateurs et à des journalistes
envers lesquels elle cache mal sa
détestation.
Est-ce la politique de votre
gouvernement, de piétiner
l'indépendance et le pluralisme
des médias sous prétexte qu'ils
agacent le pouvoir en place?
C'est certes très contrariant,
mais toute la presse ne peut pas
être macroniste.
Quand allez-vous mettre fin à
cette série de pressions
inacceptables démocratiquement et
quand allez-vous respecter la
pluralité politique et les
oppositions qui sont le reflet du
choix souverain du peuple?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Une fois n'est pas coutume, mes
oreilles ont saigné en écoutant
votre question.
Mes oreilles ont saigné quand j'ai
cru comprendre que vous alliez
nous donner une leçon sur
l'indépendance et le pluralisme de
la presse.
Mais oreilles ont saigné parce que
votre parti politique, dirigé par
votre présidente de groupe Marine
Le Pen, a censuré une chaîne
d'information, BFMTV, parce
qu'elle avait fait un choix
éditorial et avait recruté un
journaliste de "Quotidien".
Mes oreilles ont saigné quand je
me suis rappelé qu'en 2017, 28
sociétés de journalistes
épinglaient les pratiques de votre
parti après que madame Le Pen a
décrété que les journalistes n'en
étaient pas, ciblant "Quotidien".
Vos leçons, gardez-les!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Caroline Parmentier: Comment
pouvez-vous comparer des relations
tumultueuses avec l'ingérence
d'une ministre de la Culture qui
distribue les aides?
Vous venez de faire la preuve de
votre malaise.
Nous ne voulons pas nous retrouver
en Corée du Nord.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Laurent Alexandre,
pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Laurent Alexandre: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Traversez la rue, faites le tour
du Vieux-Port, et vivez dans le
monde d'Emmanuel Macron!
Plus de 5 millions de chômeurs
sont en France pour 364.000
emplois vacants.
Vous stigmatisez les chômeurs
alors que nous devrions leur
tendre la main.
On dirait que vous voudriez que
les pauvres aient honte d'être
pauvres.
Votre vision est dogmatique et
démagogique.
Qui ici a déjà vécu avec 607 euros
par mois?
Vous avez présenté une loi de
refonte du service public de
l'emploi pour conditionner le
versement du RSA à 15 à 20h
d'activité.
Qu'en est-il de l'expérimentation
dans 18 départements?
Dans l'Aveyron, cela a débuté le 9
mai.
J'ai rencontré des travailleurs
sociaux très inquiets.
De nombreux allocataires au RSA
ont besoin d'un accompagnement
global et individualisé, et non
d'être menacés de sanction.
Pour postuler à un emploi, il faut
avoir la capacité physique et
psychique.
Quoi qu'en dise Emmanuel Macron,
serveur est un vrai métier qui ne
s'improvise pas.
Or, les sommes consacrées à
l'accompagnement social et
professionnel des demandeurs
d'emploi sont passées de 20% des
montants des allocations dans les
années 90 à 7%.
Il faut apporter des moyens
adéquats pour l'accompagnement
individualisé des locataires.
Vous prétendez responsabiliser les
chômeurs avec des droits et des
devoirs?
L'Etat remplit-il ses devoirs
quand il laisse se délocaliser ses
usines?
L'Etat remplit-il ses devoirs
quand 10 millions de personnes
dépendent de l'aide alimentaire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Vous m'interrogez sur la réforme
que nous portons sur
l'accompagnement du RSA.
Vous faites fausse route, en
réalité.
Ce que nous faisons et ce que le
Sénat va adopter, c'est de
réinvestir dans l'accompagnement
pour que nous n'ayons plus à
connaître les chiffres que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui.
Aujourd'hui, 7 ans après une
première inscription au RSA, 42%
des allocataires sont toujours au
RSA.
Aujourd'hui, les moyens consacrés
à l'insertion...
Notre politique est très claire.
C'est rappeler que nous avons la
chance d'être dans un pays où il
existe un RSA auquel on a accès
quand on n'a pas de revenu.
C'est rappeler que la puissance
publique a un devoir qui est de
proposer un accompagnement social
et professionnel.
Aujourd'hui, seulement 43% des
allocataires ont un accompagnement
professionnel.
Lorsqu'il y a un contrat
d'engagement réciproque, avec des
activités adaptées d'insertion et
de formation pour permettre le
retour à l'emploi, et lorsque les
engagements sont tenus, il y a un
principe de comptabilité qui peut
aller jusqu'à la suspension des
allocations.
Vous dites avoir rencontré des
travailleurs sociaux.
Les habitants de l'Aveyron, je les
plains.
Vous faites une description
pathétique de leur territoire.
Dans votre département, il y a des
élus, comme le président du
conseil départemental, qui croient
que le RSA n'est pas une fatalité.
Heureusement que certains élus
pensent que la précarité n'est pas
une fatalité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
S'il vous
plaît, madame Panot!
La parole est à monsieur...
La parole est à monsieur David
Taupiac, pour le groupe LIOT.
- David Taupiac: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur, la semaine dernière,
par deux fois, le Gers a été
frappé par des épisodes
météorologiques graves.
Des pluies torrentielles, des
orages et des chutes de grêle ont
provoqué des inondations, des
glissements de terrain et des
dommages considérables.
Un tiers du vignoble des côtes de
Gascogne a subi des dommages
conséquents.
Les pertes matérielles sont
importantes, et de nombreuses
familles sont dans une situation
précaire.
Je tiens à saluer l'activité et le
professionnalisme de l'ensemble
des services de secours et des
services départementaux
préfectoraux qui se sont mobilisés
pour répondre avec efficacité aux
besoins des populations touchées.
Dans ce contexte critique, une
reconnaissance rapide de
catastrophe naturelle doit être
engagée pour permettre de
débloquer les dispositifs d'aide
et de soutien appropriés pour les
sinistrés et pour les
collectivités locales, tant en
matière d'assistance financière
immédiate que de facilitation de
procédures de reconstruction.
Cette mesure d'urgence est
indispensable pour une reprise
rapide de la vie quotidienne dans
notre département.
Au-delà de cet épisode récent,
l'ensemble du sud-ouest est
confronté depuis quatre ans à la
répétition de ces phénomènes
extrêmes.
Face à cette bascule écologique,
toute notre politique d'adaptation
doit être repensée.
Cela doit passer par la mise en
place de mesures d'accompagnement
et de prévention pour renforcer
les territoires, mais également
avec des investissements dans des
infrastructures résistantes.
Monsieur le ministre, pouvez-vous
nous assurer que la reconnaissance
de catastrophe naturelle sera
activée dans les plus brefs
délais?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Gérald Darmanin,
ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Je voudrais à mon tour avoir un
mot pour les habitants de votre
beau département du Gers qui ont
été, en effet, touchés suite à une
alerte Météo France le mardi 20,
puis le mercredi 21 juin.
Suite à des passages extrêmement
orageux, de nombreuses communes
ont été touchées, et de nombreux
agriculteurs, entreprises et
particuliers ont connu de graves
désagréments.
Le préfet a ouvert son centre
opérationnel et les forces de
police et gendarmerie ont sécurisé
la zone.
Je voudrais confirmer qu'à la
mi-juillet, les catastrophes
naturelles pourront être reconnues
rapidement.
Il faut que les communes puissent
prendre contact avec les
sous-préfectures et les services
de l'Etat, qui vont les aider.
Je voudrais rappeler que les
dégâts causés par le vent, la
pluie et la grêle sont exclus par
le législateur parce qu'il y a des
contrats d'assurance.
En revanche, les inondations et
les coulées de boue ouvrent un
droit à cette reconnaissance.
Pour ceux qui n'ont pas
d'assurance qui pourrait recouvrir
ces dégâts, les travaux les plus
urgents des communes pourront se
faire.
Je me rendrai dans votre
département pour voir l'étendue
des difficultés.
Nous trouverons les solutions pour
accompagner chacune et chacun des
habitants du Gers.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Karl
Olive pour Renaissance.
- Karl Olive: Ma question
s'adresse à la ministre des Sports
et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques.
J'ai un grand bonheur à voir la
flamme olympique traverser les
Yvelines.
L'été prochain, les yeux du monde
seront rivés sur notre pays.
Des millions de spectateurs
assisteront à ces jeux et des
millions pourront les regarder
depuis chez eux.
Ces Jeux Olympiques seront
précédés d'une magnifique fête
populaire qui traversera nos
villages et nos villes.
Celles du relais de la flamme
olympique.
Cette flamme, allumée le 16 avril
2024 à Olympie, arrivera sur nos
côtes et débutera son parcours le
8 mai prochain.
S'ensuit une traversée de notre
territoire exceptionnel.
L'occasion de découvrir notre
savoir-faire et notre diversité.
S'en suivra aussi une évidence:
nous pouvons faire nation par le
sport.
Ce seront avant tout les Jeux
Olympiques de la France entière.
Les habitants des Yvelines seront
témoins privilégiés de cela en
accueillant la flamme olympique.
De nombreuses villes de région
parisienne en auront également
l'occasion.
Je veux remercier le conseil
départemental des Yvelines et tous
les participants.
Cette flamme olympique, c'est un
symbole: le partage qui rassemble
et qui met la lumière sur notre
sport et sur notre culture.
Comment les porteurs de flammes
seront-ils choisis?
Comment faire rêver 68 millions de
compatriotes à s'enflammer pour
ces jeux 100 ans après 1924?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à la ministre des
Sports.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra: Ce
parcours de la flamme olympique va
être historique.
Il va traverser 59 départements et
5 territoires d'outre-mer.
Il va mettre en avant ce que la
France a de meilleur, son
patrimoine historique.
Je pense à Versailles, au mémorial
de Verdun, aux plages du
Débarquement, aux grottes de
Lascaux.
Il va également traverser ces
beaux paysages, comme la baie de
Somme et nos montagnes.
Nous allons traverser également le
Panthéon et nos vignobles.
Je pense aussi à notre industrie,
à notre ingénierie, avec le viaduc
de Millau et avec le Centre
spatial de Guyane.
Nous verrons également notre
patrimoine sportif, comme le
vélodrome.
Tout ça va être mis à l'honneur.
Ce parcours va être aussi
l'occasion de faire rayonner nos
idéaux en mettant en lumière les
grands marqueurs de notre
démocratie.
Je suis fière de dire que dans cet
hémicycle, la flamme olympique
passera par l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat.
Maintenant que le parcours est
connu et dévoilé, les
collectivités, que je veux saluer
pour leur investissement et leur
engagement, vont pouvoir passer à
la phase opérationnelle de
programmation des animations
festives, culturelles et sportives
de ce relais, en s'appuyant sur
des comités qui regorgent d'idées.
J'ai pu le voir hier dans le
Finistère.
Dans le même temps, les
collectivités vont choisir d'ici
la fin de l'année leurs relayeurs,
des personnes inspirantes,
engagées pour le sport et le
bien-être de la société.
Tout cela va marquer un véritable
coup d'envoi de la mobilisation de
tous les territoires derrière
cette aventure olympique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Isabelle
Périgault pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Isabelle Périgault: Ma question
s'adresse à la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur.
Chaque semaine, je reçois
dans ma permanence des jeunes
lycéens et leurs familles perdus
dans les méandres de Parcoursup.
Cette plate-forme, censée gérer
les voeux d'affectation de nos
jeunes étudiants, depuis 2018, est
l'objet de trop nombreuses
critiques lorsqu'elle publie ces
premiers résultats, et cela malgré
les prétendues améliorations
annoncées successivement et qui
n'ont rien changé.
Leurs parents et les enseignants
sont surpris des résultats des
enfants.
Comment expliquer que même
certains élèves avec de très bons
dossiers ne soient pas reçus dans
les écoles demandées?
Les critères sont différents selon
les établissements et ne sont pas
lisibles sur la plate-forme.
Absence de hiérarchisation des
voeux, délais courts pour se
décider une fois que les réponses
sont positives, difficulté de
gérer les listes d'attente et bien
sûr, le cas des élèves non
affectés.
Ce n'est plus possible!
Depuis 2022, et je vous avais
aussi alertée sur cette situation,
plus de 10% n'avaient pas d'offre
d'affectation au dernier jour de
la phase principale.
Que va-t-il en être cette année?
Que vont devenir ces jeunes qui se
retrouvent dans une filière par
défaut quand ils ont été affectés
sur leur quatrième choix?
Absence de motivation et parfois,
vocations gâchées.
Sans compter tous ceux qui sortent
de cette forme en postulant
directement dans des
établissements privés.
Ce système décourage notre
jeunesse qui ne se sent pas
considérée.
Ils ont le sentiment que la France
ne leur offre pas la possibilité
d'étudier sereinement.
Ma question est simple.
Que comptez-vous faire pour
définitivement mettre fin à ces
situations insensées qui leur font
prendre un mauvais départ dans
leurs études supérieures?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Sylvie
Retailleau.
- Sylvie Retailleau: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Je vais peut-être vous répondre en
trois points.
Je vais vous rappeler ce qu'il y
avait avant et vous demander ce
que vous proposez.
Avant, il y avait APB et les
tirages au sort.
Avant, il y avait les queues
devant les comptoirs d'inscription
parce qu'il fallait y aller en
présentiel.
Parcoursup, c'est un outil qui
permet à tous les étudiants et à
leurs familles d'avoir l'ensemble
de la formation, la visibilité de
la formation, et un seul guichet.
Deuxièmement, qu'il faille
l'améliorer et que l'on continue à
écouter, ce que l'on fait depuis
cinq ans, oui, nous allons
continuer.
Nous continuerons à améliorer la
transparence de cette plate-forme.
Quand je vous entends dire ce que
nous avons fait, alors que
beaucoup de gens travaillent
derrière cette plate-forme, c'est
un manque de respect des gens,
dans les lycées, dans les
établissements, sur la plate-forme
Parcoursup.
Nous avons amélioré la
transparence des informations.
Effectivement, je vous rejoins, il
est important de donner cette
information et cette transparence.
Cette année, nous avons été plus
exigeants vis-à-vis des formations
pour améliorer cette transparence
de l'information.
Un chiffre sur le terrain, et j'y
ai été toutes les semaines et j'y
ai été pendant 35 ans avec eux,
pour voir avec les étudiants et
les élèves.
Je les connais!
Dernier chiffre!
C'est effectivement 9 lycéens sur
10 qui ont reçu une proposition et
un accompagnement qui existe.
Notre objectif, c'est de ne
laisser personne au bord du
chemin.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Géraldine
Bannier pour le groupe démocrate.
- Géraldine Bannier: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Education nationale.
Les enseignants en lettres
classiques, qui ne sont pas les
seuls concernés, alertent
aujourd'hui sur le recrutement de
leurs pairs.
Le concours 2023 risque d'être à
nouveau problématique.
Le nombre de professeurs de
lettres classiques pourraient
retrouver le niveau de 2022, soit
55 postes pourvus sur les 134
proposés au concours du CAPES.
Seuls 47 candidats sont
admissibles pour 134 postes.
En 2010, c'était encore 242
candidats pour 170 postes.
En 2022, on comptait seulement 160
candidats au CAPES et 425 à
l'agrégation.
Ce déficit met en danger
l'enseignement du latin et du grec
en France.
En 2022, les chiffres des lycéens
et des collégiens qui apprenaient
le latin et le grec étaient trop
bas.
Je peux en témoigner.
L'enseignement de ces langues est
compliqué.
Accéder à cet enseignement est un
facteur de réussite, et ce, quand
on n'a pas toutes les chances au
départ.
Du fait de l'absence d'option,
cela rend cette option ardue.
Monsieur le ministre, quelles sont
les mesures envisagées afin de
promouvoir les lettres classiques
auprès des jeunes?
Afin de garantir un nombre de
postes minimums pour cette
merveilleuse discipline?
Je profite d'un aparté.
Je suis également préoccupée par
la question de mes collègues sur
les urgences en Mayenne!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Carole
Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Permettez-moi d'excuser le
ministre de l'Education nationale
et de la Jeunesse, en déplacement
à Marseille avec le président de
la République.
Cette question nous permet de
redire à quel point cette question
du recrutement des enseignants et
l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant est au coeur de nos
préoccupations.
C'est quelque part le gage de la
qualité du fonctionnement du
service public de l'éducation.
Elle est au coeur de nos
préoccupations.
Vous l'avez dit, depuis plusieurs
années, nous constatons une
diminution du nombre de candidats
à l'ensemble des concours au
recrutement du premier et du
second degré.
Que faisons-nous pour y remédier?
Nous sommes pleinement engagés
pour revaloriser ce métier,
essentiel encore une fois pour la
nation, et pour placer l'école au
coeur de nos stratégies.
C'est plus d'un an de travail et
de concertations organisées.
Comme le président s'y était
engagé lors de la campagne, il y
aura des rémunérations pour tous
les personnels de l'éducation, et
bien sûr les professeurs, qui
seront revalorisés dès cette
rentrée prochaine.
C'est un budget historique, je le
rappelle.
C'est plus de 3 milliards d'euros
qui seront dédiés à ces
augmentations.
Tous les résultats d'admission ne
sont pas encore tombés pour
pour les lettres classiques, ce
sera le 30 juin.
Les premiers résultats montrent
que notre politique commence à
porter ses fruits.
Pour la première fois, et ce
depuis plusieurs années, les
résultats aux concours sont en
progression.
Le taux d'admissibilité grimpe de
7,5%.
Comme vous l'avez dit, ce n'est
pas encore le cas pour les lettres
classiques.
Cet enseignement est essentiel.
C'est pour cela que la sixième est
refondée avec l'enseignement du
latin et du grec pour les sessions
d'approfondissement et de soutien.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Sophia
Chikirou pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Sophia Chikirou: Madame la
présidente, madame la Première
ministre, mon propos vise le
gouvernement et aussi celles et
ceux, ici présents, qui sont des
actionnaires de la compagnie
pétrolière TotalEnergies.
J'ai rencontré quatre Ougandais
venus à Paris pour le sommet de
pacte financier mondial.
Ils essayent d'attirer l'attention
des Français sur les agissements
de TotalEnergies en Ouganda et en
Tanzanie.
Ils représentent plus de 100.000
victimes du projet de l'oléoduc.
Ils s'interrogent.
Comment Emmanuel Macron, qui
soutient les projets de Total, ose
se présenter au monde comme
champion de l'écologie?
Le greenwashing, c'est peut-être
vendeur en Europe, mais en
Afrique, il tue.
Violation des droits de l'homme,
arrestations arbitraires,
corruption, destruction de la
nature...
En vous rangeant du côté de
TotalEnergies, vous cautionnez ces
agissements.
Je dénonce le double jeu de votre
gouvernement sous influence.
Vous parlez d'aider les pays
pauvres, mais la seule aide que
vous apportez, c'est celle qui
consiste à former les militaires
ougandais par l'armée française
pour faire le sale boulot
d'oppression
des opposants au projet de Total.
Je vous demande de prendre vos
responsabilités!
Allez-vous cesser de soutenir ce
projet?
Puisqu'il y a des actionnaires de
TotalEnergies sur nos bancs,
n'avez-vous pas honte de jeter
dans la misère des milliers de
personnes?
Comptez-vous fermer les yeux sur
les crimes commis pour protéger
vos dividendes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Catherine
Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Je n'ai pas à commenter les
activités d'une société privée.
Mais puisque vous parlez du sommet
de Paris pour un nouveau pacte
financier mondial, parlons-en.
Paris a accueilli ce sommet
rassemblant des centaines de chefs
d'Etat et de grands dirigeants.
Il y avait également des
représentants de la société civile
et du secteur privé.
Ce sommet a été utile.
Il a permis de forger un consensus
qui affirme que lutte contre la
pauvreté et lutte pour la
transition écologique ne sauraient
être opposées.
Le document qui a été lu en
clôture de ce sommet par le
président, l'agenda pour les
peuples et la planète, associe les
gouvernements, les chefs d'Etat
et les entreprises privées.
Pour plus de solidarité, les
projets sont là.
Je voudrais vous en donner
quelques exemples.
Je pense par exemple aux résultats
concrets que ce sommet a permis
pour la Zambie.
Elle va voir sa dette structurée.
Je pense aux petits Etats
insulaires qui verront des fonds
en cas de catastrophe naturelle.
Je pense aux bénéficiaires de la
transition énergétique.
Voilà quelques exemples.
Madame la députée, la solidarité
internationale, il y a ceux qui en
parlent et il y a ceux qui la
pratiquent.
C'est sous le mandat du président
de la République que l'aide de la
France au développement durable a
été augmentée.
Je suis fière du statut de la
France à l'étranger pour la
solidarité et pour l'écologie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
- Sophia Chikirou: Vous répondez à
côté de la plaque.
En Ouganda, TotalEnergies est
responsable d'agressions contre
les communautés.
La diplomatie française en est
complice.
Vous devrez en rendre compte au
moment venu.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est au Rassemblement
National.
- Catherine Jaouen: Une question à
monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur.
Dans ma circonscription, nous
sommes à la 264e place sur 273 du
palmarès national.
La délinquance caractérisée par le
trafic de stupéfiants, les vols,
les atteintes à l'intégrité
physique, tout cela s'est
considérablement aggravé.
Certains ont déserté la ville
d'Avignon.
Les politiques se sont révélées
défaillantes, tant dans le
recrutement d'agents de police
municipaux que dans
l'investissement nécessaire à la
surveillance de la ville.
Le rapport des comptes de février
2023 les définit ainsi: ce sont
des zones géographiques
caractérisées par des difficultés
plus importantes qu'ailleurs.
En 2013, le préfet du Vaucluse
qualifiait déjà deux quartiers de
la ville d'Avignon de zones de
sécurité prioritaire.
En 2023, 7 quartiers plus le
centre-ville sont désormais
concernés, c'est-à-dire la
totalité de la ville.
La signature de ce contrat de
sécurité intégrée, vous en avez
délégué une partie de vos
fonctions régaliennes, au mépris
de la sécurité des habitants
d'Avignon.
Pourquoi avez-vous fait le choix
de ne pas caractériser Avignon
comme un quartier de reconquête
républicaine, alors que les
chiffres de la délinquance explosent
et que tous les
quartiers sont exposés?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Madame la députée, je souhaite
vous féliciter pour votre élection
comme députée puisque vous
remplacez un député qui, à la
suite d'un incident avec une
mosquée franco-turque, n'est plus
parmi nous.
Il a quand même inauguré une
mosquée franco-turque et vous
l'avez exclu de votre groupe.
Il faut quand même le dire.
Vous pensiez que ça ne se verrait
pas, mais ça s'est un peu vu.
Nous sommes passé à 374 policiers
dans le Gard.
En plus, il y a une unité de CRS.
J'ai un désaccord avec le maire de
Nîmes.
Je parlais du département du
Vaucluse, pardon.
J'ai un désaccord avec le maire de
Nîmes.
Non, je n'ai pas signé de contrat
de sécurité intérieure.
Brouhaha
J'ai un désaccord...
J'ai un désaccord avec la maire
d'Avignon...
Excusez-moi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît.
- Gérald Darmanin: Dans votre
département, nous avons eu 43% des
trafiquants interpellés depuis un
an.
Nous avons plus de cocaïne saisie
depuis un an.
Nous avons plusieurs points de
deal qui ont été démantelés.
Nous sommes prêts à travailler
avec tous les élus de la
République, du moment qu'ils
soutiennent les policiers et
qu'ils accompagnent le déploiement
de la vidéosurveillance, le
travail de la police pour lutter
contre l'insécurité et contre la
drogue.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse?
- Catherine Jaouen: Ma réponse sera
nettement plus claire que la
vôtre.
Vous allez sur le terrain des
chiffres.
8,5% de délinquance en plus.
Plus de violence contre les femmes
en 2022.
23% de coups...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Damien
Adam pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Damien Adam: Merci.
En novembre 2022, le président de
la République a demandé aux sites
industriels les plus émetteurs de
gaz à effet de serre de présenter
leur plan de route de
décarbonation.
S'il s'est engagé sur une
décarbonation ambitieuse, l'Etat
serait au rendez-vous avec un
soutien ambitieux.
L'industrie pèse en France une
grande partie des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre.
Il est donc crucial que ses
acteurs s'engagent rapidement dans
la décarbonation de ses activités.
L'industrie est le seul secteur
économique qui s'est le plus
décarboné en France, avec une
baisse de 50% depuis 1993.
La désindustrialisation a supprimé
des milliers d'emplois et cela a
permis de réduire nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre.
Plus de 300 usines ont été créées,
depuis.
Nous devons aller plus loin et
accélérer notre
réindustrialisation.
Le tout, en réduisant nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre,
d'ici 2050.
C'est tout l'enjeu du projet de
loi que nous étudierons
prochainement.
J'ai visité une usine près de
Rouen, qui fait partie des usines
les plus émettrices.
Le même jour, la Première ministre
présidait un conseil sur ce sujet.
Pouvez-vous nous présenter les
conclusions sur le projet
écologique et l'établissement de
la stratégie française sur le
climat?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Roland
Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci beaucoup.
Le 8 novembre dernier, le
président de la République nous a
rassemblés et nous a demandé
d'élaborer une feuille de route de
décarbonation pour les 50 sites
les plus émetteurs.
C'est 60% de l'industrie, 45
mégatonnes de CO2 par an.
Autant que les logements français.
Il y en a plusieurs chez vous.
A eux quatre, ils représentent 16%
de ces émissions.
Les industriels ont joué le jeu.
Ils ont rempli leur part du
contrat.
J'ai eu l'honneur de présenter à
la Première ministre et au Conseil
national la feuille de route des
50 sites.
Ils sont prêts à réduire leur
émission de 50% d'ici 2030, et à
les éliminer totalement d'ici
2050.
Nous devons pousser les Français à
adhérer à cette transition
écologique.
Il y aura un appel à projet qui va
soutenir la décarbonation des
principaux sites.
1 milliard d'euros seront annoncés
des vendredis.
Cela va permettre le défi français
de la capture du carbone.
C'est ce qui reste quand on a tout
essayé.
Pour ça, on a besoin d'informer
les Français et les Françaises de
ces défis-là.
On va lancer une grande enquête
publique qui va nous permettre de
nous assurer que l'on pourra
réaliser ce grand défi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Elisa
Martin pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Elisa Martin: Merci beaucoup.
Cette question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre.
Le 25 janvier 2023, le comité des
droits de l'enfant des Nations
Unies constate que l'Etat français
viole plusieurs articles de la
Convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant.
Ce même comité a partagé ses
observations finales.
Parmi elles, il regrette que parmi
ces recommandations, la situation
des enfants demandeurs d'asile
migrant reste inchangée.
Pendant 71 jours, faute de
solution, plus de 500 mineurs non
accompagnés n'ont eu d'autre choix
que de se réfugier dans une école
désaffectée.
Votre gouvernement assume de
choisir l'abandon et
l'indifférence au détriment du
respect de la présomption de
minorité, pourtant fondée en
droit.
Confrontés à des conditions de vie
indécentes, le 20 juin 2023,
Journée mondiale des réfugiés, ces
jeunes gens se rassemblaient en
face du Conseil d'Etat, pour faire
valoir leurs droits, accompagnés
d'associations et de militants.
Alors que la police a bien
d'autres choses à faire, les
consignes furent la matraque, la
destruction de leurs tentes, les
arrestations arbitraires et pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux,
placement en centre de détention
administrative, et ce, malgré 11
condamnations à ce sujet par la
Commission européenne des droits
de l'homme.
Aujourd'hui, ces 500 mineurs sont
toujours à la rue.
Savez-vous seulement où ils sont?
Nous, depuis hier soir, nous
l'ignorons.
Droit d'asile entravé, conditions
indécentes, états physiques et
psychiques déplorables, détentions
arbitraires...
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin, votre
ministre de l'Intérieur, condamne
les propos du RN en leur
reprochant de laisser mourir des
enfants en Méditerranée.
Pourquoi acceptez-vous cela sur le
sol français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à la secrétaire d'Etat chargée de
l'Enfance.
- Charlotte Caubel: Merci.
A qui faites-vous ce procès en
inhumanité et en non-respect de
l'Etat de droit?
Le gouvernement est extrêmement
clair sur ses principes: tout
enfant, quel que soit sa
nationalité, s'il est isolé sur
notre territoire, doit faire
l'objet d'une protection dans le
dispositif de droit commun.
En France, ce dispositif, c'est la
protection de l'enfance qui est de
la compétence du département.
Vous faites donc un procès
peut-être au département de Paris
qui est compétent pour mettre à
l'abri les mineurs sur son
territoire.
Vous faites donc un procès à la
mairie de Paris de ne pas avoir
constaté la minorité
de ces enfants.
Vous faites aussi un procès
peut-être au juge des enfants qui
aura à statuer sur la minorité de
ces enfants dans quelques jours.
Vous faites donc un procès à des
personnes, peut-être à la mairie
de Paris, qui ont choisi de ne pas
requérir la force publique pour
évacuer cette école.
Certes, elle était dans le 16e
arrondissement...
Pour ne pas évacuer cette école,
ne pas utiliser la force...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît, vous n'avez pas la parole!
- Charlotte Caubel: Vous faites un
procès à la mairie de Paris et au
préfet de Paris, qui ont choisi
d'offrir un hébergement d'urgence
à l'ensemble de ces jeunes gens,
comme vous dites.
Vous faites peut-être un procès
aux associations qui utilisent ces
jeunes migrants pour les mettre en
situation de se mettre hors-la-loi
en occupant illicitement deux
sites, cette école et le parvis.
Je ne suis pas juge, je ne suis
plus procureur, mais j'agis au nom
du gouvernement.
Le ministre s'est engagé à
interdire le placement des
mineurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
- Charlotte Caubel: Nous avons mis
des moyens, nous sommes dans
l'action...
Vous êtes dans l'accusation et le
jugement!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Sabrina
Sebaihi pour le groupe écologiste.
- Sabrina Sebaihi: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le ministre, ce matin, à
Nanterre, un mineur de 17 ans
a été tué à bout portant
après un contrôle routier.
J'adresse à sa famille nos
sincères condoléances.
Tout comme le maire de Nanterre,
je souhaite que les enquêtes
ouvertes par la justice et l'IGPN
permettent de faire au plus vite
toute la lumière sur les
circonstances exactes de ce drame.
Nous reconnaissons tout comme vous
l'action difficile et risquée que
mènent les forces de l'ordre
partout dans notre pays.
Ils sont bien souvent les premiers
à répondre face au danger, mais
l'usage des armes ne doit se faire
que dans des cas très précis qui
représentent un danger vital.
Les images de Nanterre ce matin
sont terribles.
Contrairement à ce que certains
ont affirmé, aucun policier ne se
trouvait devant lui quand il était
en mouvement.
Le jeune homme n'a pas foncé sur
les policiers, comme l'affirment
les professionnels de la
récupération politique à l'extrême
droite.
Nous avons sur l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux une vidéo qui
dément cette version.
Cette affaire n'est pas isolée.
Pire, nous constatons une hausse
des cas, comme à Nice ou à Paris
en automne dernier.
J'aimerais vous poser une
question: pourquoi, dans notre
République, le refus d'obtempérer
peut être passible d'une balle
dans la poitrine ou dans la tête?
Pourriez-vous nous préciser qui,
parmi notre population, est soumis
à cette loi d'exception?
Pour nous, il faut revenir sur la
loi du 28 février 2017.
Elle est trop ambiguë dans sa
formulation.
Si le refus d'obtempérer est un
délit passible de trois ans
d'emprisonnement, il n'est pas
passible de la peine de mort.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée, ce matin, deux
motards de la préfecture de police
ont procédé à un contrôle.
Nous ne connaissons pas les
conditions exactes puisque les
policiers sont auditionnés en ce
moment par les services de
justice.
Deux enquêtes ont été confiées à
l'IGPN.
Je veux, moi aussi, comme le maire
de Nanterre, que je salue, avoir
le plus rapidement possible, pour
la famille, pour la ville, mais
aussi pour les policiers, les
résultats de cette enquête en
respectant les procédures
judiciaires.
Je vais vous dire que je suis très
attaché à la protection de
l'innocence des accusés, notamment
celui qui a tiré, le policier qui
va rencontrer la justice.
Je ne suis pas juge ni procureur
de la République.
Je veux être attentif à la
présomption d'innocence.
Permettez-moi de ne pas être
d'accord avec la fin de votre
question.
Depuis la loi de 2017, j'ai eu
l'occasion de lire qu'il y a eu
moins de tirs et moins de cas
mortels qu'avant 2017.
Dans de très nombreux cas,
malheureusement, des policiers et
des gendarmes sont morts de refus
d'obtempérer.
Dans de nombreux cas, il ne s'agit
pas de mélanger avec le cas de ce
matin, ce sont des familles de
policiers de gendarmes qui
pleurent leurs enfants.
Le refus d'obtempérer ne peut pas
être accepté, mais il n'est pas
non plus capable d'accepter que
des policiers tirent à portant sur
des jeunes hommes ou des jeunes
femmes.
Il faut respecter le deuil des
familles et la présomption
d'innocence des policiers.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Stéphanie Kochert,
pour Horizons.
- Stéphanie Kochert: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
du Travail.
Permettez-moi d'abord d'associer
ma collègue à cette question.
Elue d'une circonscription
frontalière, une grande partie des
salariés travaillent en Allemagne.
Je suis interpellée
quotidiennement par mes
concitoyens qui bénéficient de
l'accord-cadre sur l'application
de l'article 16 du règlement
européen de 2004 relatif au
télétravail.
Ce texte a adapté la possibilité
de recours au télétravail depuis
la pandémie.
Une dérogation a été instituée
pour permettre aux travailleurs
frontaliers de pouvoir
télétravailler plus de 25% de leur
temps de travail sans que leur
affiliation à la Sécurité sociale
n'en soit modifiée.
Malheureusement, ce dispositif
prend fin au 30 juin.
C'est-à-dire vendredi.
Je m'étonne de constater que
certaines entreprises ont exprimé
à mes concitoyens frontaliers le
souhait de revenir au
fonctionnement antérieur à la
pandémie, du fait de l'absence de
renouvellement de cet accord.
Pourtant, le télétravail a permis
de maintenir l'activité économique
des emplois.
Il s'est imposé comme une
modalité.
Cette évolution s'est révélée
bénéfique pour nos concitoyens au
quotidien: diminution de
l'empreinte carbone, meilleure
qualité de vie.
Un tel retour en arrière pourrait
être perçu comme une inégalité de
traitement entre les citoyens
européens.
De l'autre côté de la frontière,
les travailleurs allemands
bénéficient de dispositions plus
souples.
Il est de notre responsabilité
collective de rendre effectives
les libertés européennes.
C'est une opportunité de donner
corps à cette citoyenneté.
Ma circonscription est un
témoignage parlant des bénéfices
quotidiens du projet européen à
travers des mesures concrètes dans
la santé, les secours, les
mobilités, l'éducation et le
travail.
Face à l'inquiétude de mes
concitoyens et alors que le
dispositif arrive à échéance dans
trois jours, quelles réponses
pouvons-nous leur apporter?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Je sais votre implication ainsi
que celle de la députée Roche sur
cette question transfrontalière.
Pendant longtemps, nous étions
dans une phase dérogatoire.
Le règlement de coordination des
régimes de Sécurité sociale, le
règlement 883, disait et dit
toujours que les travailleurs
frontaliers pouvaient travailler
au maximum depuis leur domicile et
que s'ils travaillaient plus d'un
jour par semaine en télétravail,
le régime social basculait vers
leur Etat de résidence.
C'est la règle qui s'est appliquée
dans la totalité de nos pays
voisins pendant de nombreuses
années.
A l'occasion de la crise Covid,
des dérogations ont été mises en
oeuvre.
A la fin du mois de juin 2022,
cela avait été arrêté.
Une nouvelle période de souplesse
a été mise en place, et elle
s'achève dans quelques jours.
Un accord multilatéral a été
négocié dans cet intervalle.
Quelles sont les conséquences?
Nous y travaillons.
Il y a un point qui nous pose des
difficultés.
C'est le fait que le régime de
l'assurance chômage et la bascule
des droits ne sont pas intégrés
dans le dispositif.
Notre volonté est de pouvoir tenir
véritablement compte des
conséquences de l'accord, mais
aussi de donner une solution à nos
compatriotes travailleurs
frontaliers.
Nous saurons trancher cela dans
les jours qui viennent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Mereana
Reid Arbelot, pour le groupe GDR.
- Mereana Reid Arbelot: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Mes chers collègues, ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Transformation et de la
Fonction publiques.
L'indemnité temporaire de retraite
a été mise en place pour compenser
la cherté de la vie dans certains
territoires.
Les abus ont mené à l'augmentation
régulière des coûts, et en 2008,
ce dispositif a commencé à
s'éteindre.
Le gouvernement central s'était
engagé à mettre en place un
dispositif de substitution et à
faire en sorte que les économies
réalisées soient réservées à
chaque collectivité concernée.
15 années ont passé, et nous
attendons toujours le résultat.
Aujourd'hui, en Polynésie
française, Nouvelle-Calédonie, en
Réunion, un agence ayant servi
l'Etat reçoit une pension égale à
30 ou 50% de son salaire actif,
contre 60% dans l'Hexagone.
L'espérance de vie y est jusqu'à
six ans moins élevée que dans
l'Hexagone et le coût de la vie y
est jusqu'à 5% plus élevé.
Le comité consultatif se réunit
pour la troisième fois le 7
juillet.
Les partenaires sociaux souhaitent
la participation active d'experts
ultramarins pour proposer des
solutions abouties.
Jusqu'ici, les experts doivent
prendre la place de leurs
représentants nationaux pour avoir
le droit de parole, alors que les
expertises sont complémentaires.
Ma question est simple:
comptez-vous intégrer à ce comité
les experts ultramarins aux côtés
des représentants nationaux afin
d'aboutir rapidement à un
dispositif de substitution
concerté et digne, et d'apporter
une réponse aux futurs retraités
et aux générations oubliées?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Stanislas
Guerini.
- Stanislas Guerini: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée Mereana Reid
Arbelot, au nom du gouvernement,
je vous souhaite la bienvenue pour
cette première question au
gouvernement.
Vous m'interrogez sur les
dispositifs de retraite des
fonctionnaires d'Etat ultramarins.
C'est un sujet qui nous mobilise.
Il faut rappeler ce qu'est l'ETR.
C'est une indemnité complémentaire
dérogatoire au service de
retraite, sans cotisations
correspondantes, qui permet à des
fonctionnaires qui font le choix
d'exercer leur retraite dans nos
territoires ultramarins, parfois
sans même y avoir exercé, d'avoir
un complément de retraite.
Cela a été décidé en 2008.
Il y a eu une extinction.
C'était il y a plus de 15 ans.
Sur 20 ans, aucun gouvernement et
aucune majorité n'a remis en cause
cette extinction de ce dispositif
dérogatoire.
Ce n'est pas notre intention.
Il y a des conséquences sociales.
Le président de la République
avait pris cet engagement de
mettre en place un comité qui
réunit l'ensemble des élus
parlementaires ultramarins, des
organisations syndicales aussi,
pour trouver des solutions.
Ce comité a été installé par ma
prédécesseure en 2022.
En 2023, le conseil se réunira le
19 juillet.
Il permettra de mettre les
scénarios sur la table, les
scénarios qui sont issus des
contributions.
Ces scénarios vont suivre deux
lignes.
Nous réfléchissons à développer
des cotisations sur les
indemnités.
Nous réfléchissons à tous les
scénarios pour apporter des
solutions aux fonctionnaires
ultramarins.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
- Mereana Reid Arbelot: J'insiste
sur le fait que la vision
ultramarine est importante.
Nous connaissons la coexistence de
ces deux visions, la vision
ultramarine et la vision
hexagonale.
C'est la réalité du terrain et la
certitude de savoir ce qui s'y
passe.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Arthur
Delaporte.
- Arthur Delaporte: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre, qui n'est plus
là.
Les socialistes ont toujours fait
de la lutte contre la corruption
une priorité en créant notamment
la Haute autorité pour la
transparence dans la vie publique
en 2013.
Pourtant, sur ce sujet, nous
pouvons mieux faire.
La France ne se classe qu'en 21e
position à l'échelle mondiale en
matière de transparence.
Ce combat contre la corruption,
c'est celui d'une association:
Anticor.
Elle a fait la preuve de son
utilité.
Son agrément avait été accordé in
extremis en 2021 à la suite de
l'intervention des socialistes.
Celui-ci a été annulé par une
décision du tribunal administratif
il y a quelques jours.
C'est une décision de justice que
nous respectons.
Elle fait d'ailleurs l'objet d'un
recours.
Cette association a fait l'objet
d'une nouvelle demande d'agrément
auprès des services de la Première
ministre.
Ma question est simple: vous
engagez-vous à ce que les services
de Matignon étudient cette
demande?
Il faut éviter que les 159
procédures judiciaires dans
lesquelles Anticor agit ne soient
sanctionnées.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député Arthur
Delaporte, j'ai été membre du
gouvernement en 2021.
Cela ne s'est pas fait sous
pression.
Vous revisitez l'histoire.
C'est bien de vous octroyer les
mérites, mais c'était le
gouvernement de l'époque qui a
pris cette décision.
C'est une décision de justice.
Cette décision peut être
contestée.
La justice avait été saisie par
les anciens membres de cette
association Anticor, qui
considéraient que l'association
devait perdre son agrément.
Bref.
Il y a un appel qui est en cours.
Vous interrogez le gouvernement
sur le sort qui sera réservé à la
demande d'un nouvel agrément qui a
été déposé par l'association
Anticor.
La Première ministre a transmis au
ministre de la Justice la demande
d'agrément pour que cela puisse
être examiné dans les meilleurs
délais.
Vous dire que les procédures
pénales qui sont en cours et dans
lesquelles Anticor s'est constitué
ne sont pas remises en cause, du
fait de l'appel suspensif, et que
la perte de l'agrément rend la
constitution de partie civile
irrecevable.
La recevabilité de la constitution
partie civile s'apprécie au jour
où le jugement intervient.
Cet amendement sera examiné avec
la plus grande attention par le
gouvernement.
C'est un point sur lequel nous
pouvons nous retrouver.
Nous voulons lutter contre toute
forme de corruption.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Arthur Delaporte: Cette
association a lancé et a tenté une
procédure en justice à son
encontre.
On pourrait questionner la
question du départ du ministre.
Je me permettrais de dire une
chose.
La démocratie, c'est un bien
fragile.
Votre gouvernement ne peut se
contenter des déclarations
d'intention, comme celle que vous
venez de faire, notamment sur le
fait de transmettre la capacité à
la HATP à donner ses agréments.
Plus largement, nous constatons la
construction en France d'un chemin
libéral.
Je profitais de cette réponse pour
dire que cela effrite notre
système démocratique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Olivier Véran: Nous avons eu un
échange respectueux.
Vous pouvez donner au ministre de
la Justice le respect qu'il
mérite.
Le garde des Sceaux est un
militant de la lutte contre la
corruption.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Laurence
Robert-Dehault, pour le
Rassemblement National.
- Laurence Robert-Dehault: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la Santé.
1,50 euro supplémentaire la
consultation, c'est l'augmentation
que vous avez accordée aux
médecins généralistes.
Cela a déclenché le mécontentement
des médecins et de leurs
syndicats.
Dans ma circonscription de la
Haute-Marne, des généralistes ont
décidé de sortir du secteur
conventionné pour passer en
honoraires libres du secteur 3.
Ce n'est pas un cas isolé.
Chaque semaine, des généralistes
annoncent leur déconventionnement.
Les Français ne seront remboursés
que de 0,61 euro par la Sécurité
sociale.
Les médecins seront encore
davantage tentés de rejoindre les
villes
moins rurales et plus riches...
Cela pénalise les plus pauvres et
la ruralité va payer l'incapacité
du gouvernement à anticiper.
Je ne blâme pas nos médecins qui
sont les moins bien payés
d'Europe.
Les Français vont payer une
consultation sans remboursement
tout en versant les mêmes
cotisations sociales.
Pendant ce temps, les clandestins
qui n'ont pas cotisé un seul sou
pour la France continuent de
bénéficier de l'aide médicale
d'Etat qui prend en charge
l'intégralité de leurs soins.
Monsieur François Braun, en
février dernier, a affirmé que le
déconventionnement pénaliserait
d'autant plus les Français en
créant une médecine à deux
vitesses.
Gouverner, c'est prévoir.
Qu'avez-vous fait jusqu'ici pour
éviter la vague de ces
déconventionnements qui s'annonce
en France?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Agnès Firmin Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la députée Laurence
Robert-Dehault, la promesse
républicaine de notre modèle
social est celle de soins pris en
charge pour tous par l'Assurance
maladie.
La convention, c'est le contrat
que le médecin passe avec
l'Assurance maladie pour que les
patients soient remboursés et
accèdent aux soins.
C'est un contrat social passé avec
la nation.
La négociation d'une nouvelle
convention n'ayant pu aboutir, un
jugement arbitral a été trouvé.
En dépit de cet effort important
et des besoins de nos concitoyens,
certains professionnels, très
minoritaires, ont fait le choix
dans certains territoires de
remettre en cause leur contrat
avec l'Assurance maladie.
Ce déconventionnement a pour cause
de pénaliser les patients,
notamment les plus fragiles.
Le règlement arbitral contient
plusieurs dispositions.
Toutes ces mesures ne sont pas
anecdotiques.
Nous sommes attentifs à entretenir
le dialogue avec les médecins.
Nous pourrons ainsi construire une
nouvelle convention avec les
professionnels.
Nous réaffirmons notre attachement
à une réponse durable et forte en
matière d'accès à la santé.
Nous en appelons solennellement à
la responsabilité des médecins qui
rompent le dialogue et rompent la
confiance que leurs patients
placent en eux.
- Laurence Robert-Dehault: Ne
voyez-vous pas l'ampleur des
drames de l'offre médicale dans
les territoires ruraux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Annie Vidal.
- Annie Vidal: Madame la ministre
chargée du Handicap, dans un an,
la France va accueillir les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de
2024.
Une occasion unique de démontrer
notre engagement envers
l'inclusion et l'accessibilité
universelle.
15.000 athlètes olympiques seront
alors réunis devant 13 millions de
spectateurs et 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs.
Nous devons être à la hauteur de
cet enjeu et offrir des conditions
d'organisation irréprochables,
notamment en ce qui concerne
l'accueil et l'accompagnement des
délégations des spectateurs venus
du monde entier, y compris celles
et ceux en situation de handicap.
Nous avons adopté des mesures
législatives nécessaires pour
assurer la bonne préparation de
ces Jeux, en particulier en termes
d'accessibilité, tant pour le
centre de santé que pour augmenter
l'offre de taxis équipés pour
prendre en charge des personnes
utilisatrices de fauteuils
roulants.
La moitié des commerces dans la
capitale ne sont pas encore
adaptées à l'accueil des personnes
en situation de handicap.
Je souhaiterais donc connaître les
mesures concrètes que le
gouvernement compte mettre en
place pour encourager et soutenir
l'adaptation des commerces en vue
de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques.
Pouvez-vous nous informer des
initiatives qui visent à améliorer
l'accessibilité des services
publics?
Ces Jeux offrent une chance
inédite de faire de la France une
nation plus sportive.
Je pense qu'ils peuvent être une
opportunité formidable de faire de
notre pays une nation plus
inclusive.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à la ministre
chargée des Personnes handicapées.
- Geneviève Darrieussecq: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Je vous remercie pour votre
question qui met le focus sur deux
exigences.
La première, c'est de bien
accueillir tous les visiteurs et
tous les athlètes à Paris lors de
ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pour réussir ces
Jeux.
Ensuite, il s'agit de permettre
que les personnes en situation de
handicap
aient un accès plein et entier à
tous leurs droits.
L'accessibilité est le sujet
majeur pour notre pays.
Les JO sont un catalyseur qui doit
être un catalyseur pour cette
accessibilité avec des services
publics et des services
numériques.
Le numérique est également un
enjeu important.
L'autre catalyseur est la
conférence nationale du handicap.
Le président de la République a
fait de l'accessibilité une
priorité et a engagé l'Etat à
hauteur de 1,5 milliard sur les
cinq ans à venir avec notamment un
fonds d'accessibilité pour les
établissements recevant du public
de cinquième catégorie.
Nous travaillons à structurer les
modalités pratiques
d'accessibilité à ce fonds.
Il faut qu'elles soient simples.
Nous travaillons également avec
mes collègues à sensibiliser les
acteurs du tourisme, les artisans,
les commerçants.
Je voudrais également dire que la
dynamique doit se passer à
l'échelle du pays entier.
Il est inadmissible qu'au 21e
siècle, les personnes en situation
de handicap vivent encore des
discriminations en lien avec le
manque d'accessibilité des espaces
numériques.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame Vidal?
- Annie Vidal: On peut toutefois
regretter que la mairie de Paris
n'ait pas anticipé davantage cette
problématique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Antoine
Vermorel-Marques, pour Les
Républicains.
- Antoine Vermorel-Marques: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Olivier Véran, porte-parole du
gouvernement.
Je viens ici vous parler d'un
petit village de France, qui se
trouve dans ma circonscription.
Dans ce village comme dans tant
d'autres, il y a encore une
épicerie, une institutrice, une
mairie.
Il y a même un médecin.
Dans ce village, il y a encore des
agriculteurs, des chefs
d'entreprise qui embauchent, des
jeunes qui souhaitent s'y
installer, mais il y a un manque:
depuis deux ans, la pharmacie est
fermée.
Une loi de 2018 interdit la
réouverture de toutes les
pharmacies dans les communes de
moins de 2500 habitants.
Des dizaines de communes en France
sont concernées.
Il y a un an et demi, en tant que
ministre de la Santé, vous avez
pris l'engagement de donner une
expérimentation à la commune pour
qu'elle puisse rouvrir une antenne
pharmaceutique.
Votre successeur, François Braun,
avait pris le même engagement il y
a six mois.
Depuis, nous n'avons aucune
nouvelle de la part du
gouvernement.
Dans ce petit village, les
habitants n'ont pas l'habitude des
manifestations et des
rassemblements.
Pourtant, hier soir, nous étions
leurs côtés.
Près de la moitié du village était
rassemblé pour souligner leur
attachement aux pharmaciens qui
exercent un métier difficile face
à la pénurie de médicaments, mais
aussi pour réclamer le maintien de
l'engagement de la part du
gouvernement.
Il n'y avait pas de violence, pas
de black block.
Pour autant, il y avait une
pancarte.
Il était écrit: "Méfiez-vous, les
ploucs aussi ont le droit de
vote."
Dans la France de 2023, faut-il
trois ans pour rouvrir une
pharmacie?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Monsieur le député Antoine
Vermorel-Marques, d'abord, il n'y
a pas de plouc dans la Loire.
C'est la plus belle région de
France.
Je réponds au nom de François
Braun qui est avec le président de
la République à Marseille.
Je suis interpellé par la
situation de votre beau village.
Je me souviens bien des
engagements que j'avais pris et
des engagements que François Braun
a pris également.
Ce n'est pas un problème
politique.
Il y a eu un problème technique
dans la mise en place
opérationnelle de la réouverture
d'une antenne de pharmacie.
Lorsque j'étais ministre ou encore
rapporteur général, je disais
qu'il fallait faire les lois les
plus simples possible.
Hélas, cette pharmacie est tombée
dans un interstice législatif, qui
mérite des corrections, notamment
pour des questions de facturation.
Je suis de tout coeur avec vous et
la population de ce village.
Les discussions vont bon train
avec l'Agence Régionale de Santé,
avec les élus du territoire.
Toutes les logiques, toutes les
nécessités vont être mises en
place.
Il y a l'article 51 que nous
avions adopté il y a quelques
années pour permettre d'être dans
un cadre dérogatoire pour mettre
en place des solutions.
Parfois, on en est là.
C'est très technique.
Ca me fera plaisir quand elle aura
rouvert.
J'espère venir vous y voir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La séance des questions
est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.